happy Friday my name is Rob this is Joey
next to me hello rope hi I don't think
we've ever streamed before we haven't
sir first time fun for something
together Joey
cuphead is out it is out it's out in the
wild we've waited 80 years for this
Haiti here's the law 81 now went into
development before I was born
oh wow yeah this game is out on sweat
let's say switch Xbox and PC Xbox of PC
yeah I played a decent amount you played
a lot I've played a little more than I
probably should have huh 115 percent how
is that possible is that your completion
yes so you beat it and then some and
then I kept going so I guess we could
jump right in maybe yeah so I think the
plan is uh I'm definitely not watch you
play because yeah this games pretty damn
hard it is yeah that's a tough one this
150 percent didn't come with several
hours of dying yeah
but later I think we'll dive into some
co-op and show that off and then
probably cancel the stream at that point
because you're now gonna watch me suck
and everyone's gonna be so hard drive is
oh alright that's fair but yeah I'm uh
I'm checking the chat guys any questions
or comments or you know happy Friday
I'll call you out yeah let's get into it
so you have beaten it yes what do you
think overall impressions is really
really good it's all it's it's just as
every bit as hard as they made it out to
be yeah and then some in some respects
like your urban so there are three
worlds yeah there are three worlds okay
so I'm gonna go back to the first one
you can see a couple of the early bosses
have you tried to their two modes for
each
you know there's a variety of different
types of levels but there's like a
regular and a simple right do you unlock
another mode after you beat it I mean
you'll see once I know I pick something
I guess yeah
the new legal in the chat says how does
the gameplay feel it is incredibly
difficult but I will say one thing the
the controls probably say more about
like how hard is because they are it's
also really really good like as tight as
can be oh my god expert we're just gonna
do regular for now yeah this is you know
one of them I think this might be like
one of the first bosses that was
revealed
I believe in like 2014 oh I want to say
yeah a lot of questions coming in you go
mine
really jumped on it
I love the intros with the announcer
okay so yeah that's one mechanic the
anything pink right you can kind of like
a double peri on it and that gives you
more so be your super ability yeah which
is on the bottom left there in the form
of like playing cards yeah
and then your supers just like I mean
you can then upgrade that so there is
like a progression tree that you can
work on put the only way to it's like
the only way to basically get new skills
is through coins right and so far my
opinion I only see those during like the
long-running gun back so you only get
the coins during the the run gun
sections there aren't enough to buy them
I think you might end up with one of
them that year we just won't have enough
money for so you can like careful with
it just know it's not a ps4 and
fortunately we'll see you down the road
Michael one would love to see on switch
[Music]
happy birthday to midday opiate Deyo
Deyo pa sure are the world's big Joey
the words are actually pretty big big I
think big enough so much that you might
like to spend time right so those like
those are the kind of over worlds yeah
each of those are three worlds
how many many levels would you say are
in each one think about six or so okay I
think the last one has a little bit more
okay
yeah local co-op we're gonna look at
that later is that are you able to play
online just oh right the only local
co-op it's just boss battle after boss
battle well we saw there was more or
less just a series of bosses I would say
yeah but then there is at the end of
each running gun section where it's the
more like platforming side-scrolling
levels that has an ending boss yeah it's
not as like big but no it's it's like a
little it's like a little bit more
substantial their like their abilities
but not like four phases worth like
these guys okay
we're playing an xbox one for the SNES
classic is today - I forgot about that
oh my god we're just going back in time
today we're so in this one right yeah
this is very like 1930 that's so cool
oh so joy you know a lot about like the
story behind this game like as far as
like how it was developed it developed
and put mainly like anime right so
everything is hand drawn everything is
hand drawn there as far as I know they
they did all the animation on pencil and
paper ii know this is probably the
hardest game to Fox and plays I know -
oh so good pretty damn good at this
point
everything was done like traditional
like true song me as recordings I think
the only thing that they did digitally
I'll put my side from like turning it
into a video game was a the colouring
process okay Wow far as they know they
did that love that visual like the
coloring is yeah they were to color all
this yeah talk that would take a lot of
time yeah I mean if you actually really
think about that would that's probably
like oh I want to say like double the
amount of time I don't know like you got
a got the consistency right yeah I don't
know that's good like a lot of the
delays were because of how much just how
much time the animation was consuming
cuz like every single change that they
had to make if they like finished it
like an idle animation and they want to
maybe move it to the left or something
like that they would have to like redraw
everything oh damn and so that's like
just hours and hours of animators time
yeah I love that solid loading screen
animation I know it's good
I love when those are done right well
all right cool oh you want to show off
maybe some of the abilities you have cuz
I know you go see you you can do like a
a weapon change during you you only get
one ability to basically swap around
with right as far as your what you shoot
that's also this guy right here in the
shop can visit him for crime
yeah I agree the pairing was really hard
I still haven't gone it down you look
like you your yeah you basically have to
do like a double jump almost yeah like
it's like you'll see it like it's like a
spin he doesn't like whacks him with the
straw it was like a little pink aura
around you right it takes a little bit
till I get the timing down especially in
like the platform like the the flying
stages are a little bit easier since you
have like more maneuverability yeah yeah
then that's what's so difficult about
those Perry's is that like there have
been times when I'm doing it and I'm not
thinking ahead because there's and then
a bullet there's like knocking the boss
is like looking staring down you about
to charger you and write a lot of things
to keep track of I guess totally it's
very much like a strong risk reward so I
look good so we got the regular pea
shooter which is like the new when I
realized it's I always thought when I
was watching the game earlier that they
were just shooting it from their fingers
but they're actually snapping their
fingers every single time is snapping
yeah yeah yeah oh and that's pretty
friggin cool
so got that one we got the spread like
in Contra we got the chaser sort of like
a homing missile I have that one those
are those are helpful for like waves of
like flying enemies yeah where a lot of
times you're like really trying to jump
around you can't really write you don't
have time you can't be precise so it's
easier just kind of like shoot and
forget and not those guys out there
that's definitely helpful we got around
about which are like boomerang welcomes
they like fly like horizontally on the
stage we have a charged blast which is
the boomerangs come back yeah I'll come
back once the charge blasts which I
actually really like I know Peter wasn't
too jazzed about it but it's like it's a
little bit more difficult to use because
you have to charge up and then let go
when you want to use it and then there's
the lobber which is like this little
bouncy ball actually kind of like that
one I might use that one okay and then
you also have oh so super abilities yeah
so we got the energy beams what's all so
what's the first one you start off with
alright so I don't think I've actually
seen me so you have like a I want to say
there are two types of supers right yeah
there's actually three the super is the
first one is the energy being you like
shoot out like hell no it looks like
milk almost and that's if you get all
the cards yeah okay
and then there's invincibility which is
you know pretty straightforward and
there's a ghost one which I still
haven't figured out how to use it but
he's like it's a big like buff ghost
that like mirrors your attacks
oh he like spins around with his fists
and he like he'll go in the direction
that you're holding up not quite sure
the easier but and then you have other
abilities to like just like like status
types yeah
so there's the one I'm using right now
is the the smoke bomb okay which allows
you to your - you can - like through
enemies without getting hurt oh that's
big yeah oh this guy this is when I
yesterday all right I stormed out of the
office for the end of the day at 6:30
just like I can't it stuff like so what
would you use that for like is it like I
start like an enemy type these frog
brothers not even reaching them dang it
oh really do you think there will
armando says do you think there will be
a super or DLC levels I think who do
mvhr said that they want to do
expansions for the game because it's
right for that I think like just having
like a pack of bosses 20 of them are so
yeah
[Music]
what's up tube I can't see what that
image is I have clay I have glasses and
I still that's a pile of salt oh yeah
okay that's fair
I was salty do you think co-op makes the
game much harder we'll take a look at
co-op later but I found out talking with
Peter is that you can he says it's very
difficult and and to a degree like
didn't have a good time with the co-op
just cuz there's there's already so many
moving car parks yeah what's going on
the stuff point on our wants to follow
your own cup yeah or mug man that's
right but the one oh the one plus was
that you get to you get to revive your
other bud right like there's a ghost if
you die like if you were to died there
your ghost would fly up and I think I
have a chance to provide you me wow that
was pretty easy cash register or no slot
machine slot machine do
- B - how much is coming 20 bucks 20
bucks 20 clams but as they would say in
30 I was looking at that list yeah 1930
slang it so listen here's my let up eggs
in coffee which means it runs smoothly
so if you guys are wondering what this
runs that eggs and coffee what is the
frame rate on this
I believe it's 60 but they do but this
I remember reading like they did
something with the like the frame
interpolation or something to make it
look like it's it runs at 24 even though
it's like stools right cuz I was me
gonna be my next question is that like
that that is an aesthetic like you don't
necessarily want 60 frames for this type
of animation yeah yeah we were looking
up best so funny we look up like 1930
slang thinking of like titles and like
if I'll go through the list it's freakin
hilarious like you just can't because
the slang was so much time has passed
that like there is a few of them that is
still around yeah a few see a few but
not many of this list I'll read a couple
later but you keep playing we want to
try expert I I'm curious I'm sure chat
is I was still arias have you tried it
I've actually uh beaten the last boss on
expert Matt Marcel wants to know can you
play as love man in Solem oh no oh what
the heck these guys clearly
this is harder already yeah
the his little gum feels smaller
gumballs were not there Oh so they'd
straight added more enemies yeah
have you not have you like never seen
that like animate like that curse that
that cartoon is before like those little
guys those little ones you're never seen
the main one damn so I guess you could
almost say like an expert mode little
jellybean Archangel yes it is I want PC
adults plus the I agree art style
Oh God says very nested have an
important this restarting the game like
the second I take damage right oh yeah
like almost remind me of like I mean
I've never played a Sonic game but I was
playing Sonic mania it was like you know
you have two stages
yeah in order to like get to the next
area and there are times it's like the
first day just like I have like no lives
left I might as well restart I no more
questions here in the chat how long is
the game says hours replies yeah just
like based on like the difficulty I want
to say you'll probably spend hours like
yeah that's not including like
abilities all the abilities and going
through them again and extra motor that
[Music]
alright with
I haven't tried actually a simple Moga I
don't know but that is just a play
anywhere title yes is there story there
is like a cool intro to the game that I
liked like the writing is great as well
yeah but I will say and you could
probably answer this better than I but
like I haven't seen much else as far as
like story story wise or cutscenes is
there is there any kind of like
conclusion in the end oh yeah the
premise itself is kind of dark yeah I
was like at first like exactly like what
it was about
yeah oh he's just like this gambler
right like it's his old deal with the
devil baby
he basically like is like held up and
he's gambling so much with his brother
that he like is now in debt and has to
like was he's basically like contracts
yeah I guess like if these are all the
ones
I get their contracts back from the
devil because they looks like that in
itself kind of reminds me of nineteen
thirties I don't like it's like
[Music]
[Music]
back scrolling up here - 98 - mariachi
me IRA I am so bad at reading names is
it only boss battle so not necessarily
there is a boss definitely in each level
but there's like is it just two types of
levels that you're kind of playing it's
just like the side-scrolling or you're
getting coins which you then use for
your progression to get skills and then
there's kind of like these ultra boss
battles this is like a serious yeah
different they're like they're like more
than just like a typical boss well
they're like Vince right or stages or
something like that but it's like one
frame and you're just kind of moving
around regular cuz yeah is just I
haven't tried out any of the bosses yet
on expert yet I love the snapping noise
yeah unfortunately this is only on xbox
and pc
did they say if they might eventually
add online co-op I think they mentioned
that they were working on or they're
going to consider like after the nice
man you wouldn't really hope to have a
good internet though like yeah you
cannot afford to have any chugging I
will say that like I'm not very good at
platformers necessarily but like I still
found the controls really precise like I
like your control is pretty on point
[Music]
this Bober is not good for this for this
one yeah yeah let's see um some other
stuff
it's mother what the ALMS maybe
abilities yeah I can measure this with
any amount of lag I know right or to
have it happen like on a really great
run in the end like during the boss I
can end up like a run gun come on I'm
gonna change the spread is really good
it's nice to that like each one of these
has a use in like different in different
fights
what about abilities under different
ways so those are your charms a few more
to get yeah but there's like extra hit
points or one extra hit point you give
coffee which auto fills your meter and
then sugar which just automatically
Perry's you're the first one that you
jump into oh I just realized these are
in relation to like things you put in
like your drink or coffee hearts yeah
hearts especially that's what I have in
mind smoke bombs - whatever I'll take my
coffee with the bakelite smoke bomb
it's not bomb this is only boss fights I
don't know I already I don't even know
how to answer that anymore like in my
opinion everyone of everything is a boss
fight in this you know like I guess in
the running guns is where you see that
with the one note oh whoa yeah so this
is the the spread this is good for like
swarms of enemies like this is a we
should do a running gun type one next
yeah and so again that's where you get
like coins that are in the scattered in
the level but what's interesting is that
you once you get the coin it does not
appear in that said level when you can't
get it again right so there's there it
is a set amount of coins meaning I mean
that's pretty tough like do you know
where the other coins are that you need
to get in order to get all these
abilities like in different levels yeah
I think I have them all but what I'm
thinking is that there are more than
just the coins in the levels yet oh no
because like in one of the in like the
very first area you talk to a guy and he
actually like gives you a point like
chef gives you so I'm wondering like
maybe and he sees probably will fill in
like the gaps where the oh wow
his nose was that's crazy how like you
just happen to have a knife or anything
that's pink again you can carry off we
can get more than your super wide look
so forth
like I have more trouble with
platforming than like actually shooting
guys it's like God like the precise that
gives me like anxiety nice dude
geez yeah let's see a kind of running
gun side-scrolling level thank you guys
for joining us cuphead curly a on Xbox
and PC what do we have on those 30
playing oh the slang les I have here you
got to incorporate that into your
commentary this slang list if you're
just joining us we were looking at 1930s
lingo slash slang and it does not work
today and unlike most of these yeah
here's one yes and coffee for if I were
to say run it runs smoothly it's eggs
and coffee would they be referring to it
I don't know a crude person is an egg
gold-digger is one that is still around
today Joey what would you call a
saxophone the National saxophone guess a
tube okay close a gobble pipe a gobble
pipe that's right
[Music]
if you're a lot of egg references no if
you're tough you're hard-boiled the
electric chair it was also known as a
hot squat hot squat that I like that
Felix the Cat someone brought that up
yeah I actually like surprised to know
how the first cartoon I used like from
the coogo wants to know does this game
have adventure mode or is just only boss
fights so this is kind of the more like
side-scrolling adventure mode like
there's there's more like interesting
things going on here and like carnival
here traveling circus I left the
foreground type Center all the music
here ragtime rising via the epic theme
for Mario World
oh my god which you can play on your
snez classic if you got one out today
yeah you're right this is totally
actually this is very much
yeah let it be show you the video of the
Tom something he's just like ah it's
like one of you to perceive the guy with
the piano yeah he's like he's like a
professional like I knew I hit ragtime
exactly so big because he's so good
sight-read exactly [ __ ] so so this guy
is able to basically like take the score
from like yeah Mario like athletic team
which is Neal again like heavily like
I'm inspired and he just gives him the
reasonable score any sight reads it yeah
he liked it he has never seen it before
and he's like you see it's so cool
because you see him like learning how to
play it like the first couple like bars
are kind of shaky and then you see him
start to learn it and figure out how the
rhythm goes and then he starts like
improvising it's like it's so impressive
I loved watching the videos spelling out
snacks and treats hats just flying
mustard relish that's the other part of
it too we're like oh I like how you took
you took bites out of them wow you
finish them off pretty quickly yes
oh so that's so that's like your
ultimate super right and then you have
legs like them like I don't know I think
the X moves okay and those those are
like single cards they can't wait and
then tally up all your cards you do that
that's pretty over quickly I mean it's
it's it's like a lot of times you you
probably want to use the X move because
you'll be able to like dangle it to like
the for that super it's only in that
horizontal beam mm-hmm let's see another
one another super yeah Tom I think his
name's Tom Breyer yeah so type in yeah
type in Breyer if you type in I would
love to pull it up I don't know how to
watch videos yeah like you only what if
we could watch it on the computer I
probably not do you know how to do that
and put like piano or something yeah Bri
er and then do then also type like
athletic theme is where I would start
cuz it's like the first video that blew
up and then like the guy kept doing tons
of different video like a game so I
think they they have like they're part
of like this ragtime piano group oh yeah
Club right and so like every week they
would meet and then he would just give
him a sheet to read and he was like kill
it yeah it's like definitely video I
always go back to once in a while that's
so freaking cool he's also got the most
insane neckbeard clavicle yeah um we did
you change up any of your skills what to
do the next oh shoot yeah well actually
this one you won't have it because it's
the the flying stages all right so best
the other thing is too is there's also
these flying stages yeah and that almost
looks like a model in the background I
think
that's kind of what they were going for
cuz uh that was home what common have
like these like you're making like
rotating uh Molly's like oh really as a
background in 30s I feel like I've seen
things like that before
interesting so playing that the plane
stages are actually except for that you
have like two different weapons that you
can use you know like this is a bomb Oh
though you're throwing the kind of
they're kind of like lobbing yeah like
this Wow super I think yeah we saw he's
like come you become the bomb you can
blow them off right and to avoid them
you can press instead of Daphne to a
smaller airplane so you can have more
maneuverability oh my god that is
heartbreaking what apparently Tom dryer
got a car accident last year he's now
unable to play the piano
oh that dude that's his like
professional life heartbreaking I wonder
if he can recover from that
so oh my god that is really sad story
this story was real interesting too
because like sight reading is apparently
to his to his level of sight reading
it's like really unique and not that
common because you have to apparently
you have to like be introduced to music
like I'd had a really early age like
like six yeah to the to the speed of
which he plays and then like in that one
video he like plays again like a little
bit faster then that filming is like it
was actually meant to be played with the
fast music okay even faster than like
the original soundtrack it's freakin
amazing
one thing I like about the game too is
that it it's like constantly mixing up
like the different phases I notice that
it's nothing that you can I mean you can
expect like three to four or even five
different types of moves right yeah but
they never come in the same sequence
yeah so you're kind of always like
sometimes when I use cats sometimes a
little throw like trash out of these
like treasure chests
hi Mark Jackson
right yeah I think you guys for joining
us we're looking at cuphead playing on
the Xbox one it's also one can see it's
out today you definitely have to be in a
nice mindset just to like make any kind
of progress in this game were there
times where you just look we're like
alright I have to come back to this
because I'm not banning anywhere or
usually while using at this game I think
one of my major strange that the game
was like time but just gets too late
like I could keep going but yeah I
should probably sleep and be well-rested
for the stream tomorrow oh that didn't
happen I just realized this is you yeah
so he like I guess stole my mind
there are gonna be times when you have
to consider like should I continue
killing the boss or like do I need
leaders yeah so someone asked yeah you
have your your two interchangeable main
weapons that you get to one you get to
change in the progression three but the
only thing that would be unlimited for
an hour limited is your super which is
like next to your health in the bottom
left there and again what would you call
it the like the secondary super 30s yes
and then like if you save all of us food
how many are there like throughout like
a level is like it goes up like five to
five hi Liz got some form Australia in
the house gams at it says so beautiful
and I concur how many bosses are there
Joey roughly I haven't counted yet there
are a lot though did you say like more
than 20 I think I want to say like total
throughout the entire game I want to say
there's 25 I mean so that's like would
you are you basically just counting like
each level like that's because there's a
boss in yet every level
right yeah
you mean like each phase are you are you
talking about I guess I don't know like
I cuz like there's the run-and-gun types
and then there's like something like
what you just played and that was like
one boss yeah with like four different
phases in there right like if I guess I
find it kind of tough to differentiate
the boss is in the stationary like
frames yeah cuz that like some of them
are like I don't know like like that I
guess that's just one boss right like
the two Frog brothers yeah it's just
like multifaceted like yeah some phases
does special do that much power more
than the e^x move or or better use five
e^x moves that's actually a really good
question because the one thing that the
game doesn't really tell you is how much
damage you're doing right other than
like after you die you can see like your
progress bar to see like okay I was
almost there
after using like the super but other
than that they don't there's no like
life bars there's no like actual numbers
for any damage good day for a swell bath
you're up
Fabrique Oh from Australia who are you
straight out of Stockton
[Music]
like that he's like breathing in with
you with his chest trying to be hard to
get that that's that's a hard move in Oh
turn it off
[Music]
[Music]
ouch hey Dan cuphead bugs would be sick
just like with this emoji basically with
his face on it yeah I buy it I'd buy
that in a heartbeat
hit it zero let's hit it
great soundtrack Nate a kid
[Music]
I'd love to know about
[Music]
like the audio even like if they like
use like an old-time like Mike put that
that intro announcer nowhere I can't
quite control him we're going like
whatever direction
[Music]
soundtrack I pull people's eggs and
coffee you said you said these fossil
have names right yeah where does this
show job it shows it right when you
start them and their names will also be
on like a checklist
[Music]
that gash is super the
[Music]
so the damage you're doing is a direct
factor unlike your your movement on the
timer right
[Music]
for that I mean it's unnecessary but
like I almost would want to see it move
like right now like I'm curious to see
like how much you know like what effect
I got like a super guys or an already at
you
[Music]
oh right into it more with this guy and
maybe move on
[Music]
[Music]
putting ruse said I found that Super
Mario ragtime and Wow yeah that video is
something else that's where I we all
have our like YouTube go to is you know
like I always go back to like some
things and that's definitely one to
check out after this treatment its and a
lot of that is the factor of like
nostalgia right like that ragtime theme
oh my god like playing Super Mario World
back today and having that like that
level was tough yeah so you would have
it they're just like green it's just
making you want to go faster pretty much
yeah
this James wants to know there's a game
here gameplay filled with editors I
don't think so now like each boss has
like four different phases or whatever
[Music]
and like you have I feel like you have
enough like different weapons a reason
yeah like that like for me I haven't
played that much but like having them
hammer the name of it the one kind of
like the homing missile weapon yeah the
chaser yeah like being able to pick a
new weapon type and then like finding
when it's viable
oh cool I know exactly when I should use
this and what every time this guy right
here is not not really working out from
that bending buff guy in the corner
oh well well you have being this guy
before yeah we can move around somewhere
else maybe try new charm or something
yeah let's get rid of the ghost so I
think also I mean you can answer this is
like when you get to like a new area and
you have like at your disposal in the
account of the overworld I want to say
like three to four different levels at a
time right like yeah if you're having
trouble with one you could probably just
try out something maybe less you can
move to to the other ones yeah right
like I feel like the running guns are
more of the I don't I would say that
they're easier right they're not as
intensive as like a boss battle older
throwing just so much at you
well this one is ultra for Oh forces
saving the page with a double vinyl for
a peg because it's a quadruple vinyl is
for the moon
oh wow I miss a coin is that when he hit
when you hit the spacebar is that when
you flip up yeah Oh dog okay
oh my god they're all tied I mean all of
these took me a while to like actually
complete like did you ever have you ever
like Donna level on the first strike
like very first right yeah I've gone
close this one oh just like hurts my
brain yeah I love the text reminds me of
a gobble pipe that guy
[Music]
second best dad says super jealous of
your cuphead shirt oh my god how'd you
get back high yet pixel counter says our
window place directly over hophead oh my
god actually I would argue it's probably
the best spot so you can actually see
the bosses if we put in the and the
right
[Music]
move to the bottom right go on - how we
doing on time probably go - uh maybe I
mean generally we go to like what twelve
thirty twelve why don't we you want to
go up maybe have we shown to jump in
yeah we should call it we should show it
all right and so for co-op
you can actually just jump in and like
hop in hop out with everyone that's
pretty neat yeah so you don't need to
like restart the game you don't need to
like lose all your progress just because
you want your friend to play so I just
yep today button just dude guess we can
be please don't have a passcode please
don't have a passcode
yeah alright so I am ugh man that knows
he's God knows he's also got a Street
straw as opposed to a bendy one Oh
straight-shooter softube robbing coming
do you wanna do you want to go it's back
to the yeah Sarla slow suck oh it won't
be bad okay why don't we start on simple
okay I'm curious because I actually
haven't tried out simply I wonder like
how much of the difference still pretty
hard oh great oh yeah actually go back
you have a bunch of take you shopping
take me shopping just buy him you have
thirty five coins cool well this is cool
the show okay so what do you what do you
recommend I start here I have I had
I have tried chasers I just like the
lock on spread is always good to have
okay
like especially for close for yourself
cuz it's like all three of the dick all
three of the beams will do some good
damage you could probably just buy them
all over for you
so we also would probably want to like
comp like you know combi major to a
degree right like maybe I take like the
homing and you do the spread yeah
I just really just start buying all them
that you got bombs that was a sugars
good sugar in like you like burying I do
what it was the sugar the sugar do
preparing um so like when you jump you
automatically parry that person so you
don't need to hit it again oh [ __ ]
that's good
make some boxes where they throw a lot
of pink stone value that's pretty good
continuously fills yes it where the
coffee is like even if you're not
shooting this will get meter help try
the whetstone actually cuz that's the
one that's one of them I don't have yet
to additional all but weakens your
attack power that's the fact that you
can't really see how much damage you're
doing already like do it now it's just
five going short alright I think I'm
good alright don't be nervous
t razor what's your question I'm sorry
any performance issues apologies when
you see it oh no no no no I haven't had
any whatsoever
let's go back to that a flower bed there
you leave the way Oh coin it was just
great hitting the trees Oh hitting the
tree Oh hidden behind this guy this axe
matt says I read somewhere that if you
equip the heart special for an extra hit
point you the damage due to enemies
decreases yeah that's correct it says
that in the actual description alright
so what was the one which that girl was
you're Joey what do you recommend
Oh spread you tried the chaser right I
tried to chase her mmm for this boss
maybe the lobber might be good cuz it's
kind of you kind of fighting up close
and then quit longer supers - okay sorry
or fire and the super that's the one
yeah you know I would go with the being
the being keep it simple and then the
charm was what we said it was the the
what sound let's try that Sonia it's
like every time you parry I'm I've
actually haven't seen yet so your first
Perry moved doubles as a damaging axe
attack huh
find out we'll find out
we're simple yeah stick havens on the
coop so let's see oh god I'm not
thinking sorry I was actually like fully
knocking sound Babs you can actually go
yeah any order you want as long as like
you'll when you go into a level you'll
have me be like and then every 2000mah
like newer areas so you can tackle it
like at any water
Oh
Oh so unlimited revives
yeah but you only the only res with
one-inch penis I try the duck thank you
[Music]
for the revive
-
[Music]
I think this is like one of my favorite
songs yeah this is pretty fantastic
[Music]
stay cool
[Music]
I was probably
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
so you can't you can't even kill that
well I got to the Perry's in the move oh
no survived how do I revive you
you have to carry like ghosts but then
once it flies away get the box yeah yeah
so they do
oh we were like standing on the flag
crap that's fine oh I've seen that
reward I'm reading chat so horrifying so
I'm not sure what fun is for you because
I changed my controls but
right yeah right now it's the barrio
just a [ __ ] how does the mind bound to
the trigger yeah that does yeah look at
the game what you really want to get
like just trying to like find like a
comfortable way of like
I do I do believe the bosses scale and
while respect
I like during the coop don't have a lot
more life even though it's a simple
still take a while
Oh rats that's fine that's fine I can
reach at now count under white where'd
you say cuz it still gonna have all the
extra light oh nice
a knockout kid that is one pissed-off
sunflower
[Music]
see - that's fair
it's a passing grade I passed I did not
die 27 times that's very rude to say
that good fun that's actually pretty fun
I let's do a running gun so that was
manageable as far as following my
character at least for me I think it was
one of the gripes are that like Peter
and you I think like specifically that
one that we played oh yeah during that
one there's like balloons being inflated
and then like a roller coaster just
driving straight through the level oh
geez oh we played that one earlier right
yeah that does sound chaotic because
there's so much platforming in that yeah
yeah did we want to move the pit for
this one we have anything set up what do
you think we should move it do you just
do that just do this just fullscreen we
don't have anything else I'm not oh we
can do right here huh yeah we gotta like
work I think it's fine I mean over here
yeah we'll just do a 4d game did you get
rid of us for a while
[Applause]
see have the smoke bomb right yeah thing
is like a lifesaver
all right let's um
I want the smoke bomb okay let's go exit
I can also remove you in the middle of
the level if I if I so please
Wow that's rude that's fine you think so
I'm just like you know what did you suck
just get out this is awkward
oh yeah you have the ax oh let's start
with a smoke bomb just like gonna feel
for like the dashing of it where's that
top right yeah the cheese I think is a
chaser in a while okay man this the
spacing in and texts for chat is they
just have just like actually
Oh No it's double double jump damn it
there you go
it takes it takes a while yeah oh wow
the smoke on though like I don't know oh
[Music]
man that's like you even have to know
God careful I know oh this is cool I
chase her too good here
oh of course
oh I got way to master the heroes has
got to really give props to the our team
on this one it looks amazing
it's it's so I've seen like you know
like one thing I kind of alluded to or
how that compared to two miles talking
about this is like you've seen games try
and do life which I'd be faithful to
like 8-bit 8-bit era right but for some
reason I feel like there's always
something like slightly missing it could
be just like might be something to do
with like the framerate or like it looks
almost too clean or something to come
out of like it's like when what things
are like pause for example in this game
they'll have that little wiggle because
like you're drawing
right like excite Luke right yeah yeah
that's good yeah like it doesn't have
that like static yeah that you like what
you would expect it feels it's breathing
yeah absolutely all right
hey you might have to resume oh thank
you these things take a lot of damage
oh god what are these things by the way
the Beatles oh no oh god it's okay you
got 3 HP use it wisely
what's here what's your secondary your
wood I should be able to do that use
that use the - like a lot oh yeah
definitely not using it
no that was you wanted to do it yeah hey
look how far I got it song pants mo bomb
is tough to like predict where you're
gonna be so you can go through and
straight up right like yeah you can like
just - like like from one side to the
other
[Music]
into no way oh what what um metallic oh
that's the the chaser I think each one
of them Peppa goodness
a certain sound to it like the
peashooter has this oh there you are oh
wait it kills me
if whoever scar there I guess oh really
you can't yeah that's what happened yeah
we turned the camera off cuz we wanted
to similar the game oh my god haha dude
you sad nice this is the run then hold
on wait door is
[Music]
dude that's really hard ultimate like
yeah well I mean for the time being no
it's not that
Joey keep leaving me behind I just can't
6 the rut 6 like you want to kill the
killer but like absolutely no good
easily just like Stan
[Music]
get the just chops in would burst
God be in sync here oh god it fell off
copy it sink
[Music]
good so these are tough because like
once you step on them dole will burn up
okay so here you go verse all right just
go forget it forget it
[Laughter]
[Music]
for you hot milk Wow oh dude oh dude if
I was here know what
believe me with no are you
this looks gnarly there's no way I would
have been able to do that nice that's it
Matt okay Bravo let's say Wow Wow oh
here's this witty alright let's do one
more and then haul it all right great
yeah all right what's next should we do
a like a level and debonair e-ink well I
love the overall music
have you seen the videos that they
posted about the the music no um you
mentioned those I gotta watch this it's
like a little preview of like the full
because they have a full jazz band like
recording all the songs
wow it's just so much fun to watch them
play hey how many boss is left in the
world one oh how many boss is left in
the world one I think we we know we
didn't do we did the frogs are in yeah
apart are you gonna need some tips if
you want to eat all those deadbeats
[Music]
expert in weaponry
[Music]
we're gonna go pirates I don't know do
we
oh wait can you go back out I won't
change my secondary sure just the lobby
rain fun I'm gonna go with sugar on this
one just want some good opportunities
for a lot of Perry's I think okay I like
this charge hold attack to increase
damage yeah that's one that I like but
it's it takes a little bit time to get
used to it okay I like it
my 1930s voice is a 9 out of 10 were USA
with the US office all rights to it yeah
yeah we're doing simple I want at least
like try to finish the level and not
just because the boat doesn't usually
start doing that I got this one come
head the lobber huh oh oh oh he's got a
pet shark get to the right whoa
[Music]
no wrong with Oh No Oh
seagulls Wow we both ate it there get on
top of the barrel can you do that no you
can see like when he when he's starting
to look evil
that's one hole
[Music]
[Music]
drop it Raph I want to work yes Oh rats
[Music]
[Music]
Pluto thank you
[Music]
I saw you playing this one that screws
up your like if you let them Tom
proposed to make this game look easy
Joey is very good this game damn dude
you beat it on expert right at least one
level we had a 115 percent completion
I see he there's actually another phase
that he didn't actually go to hmm I
guess that's what yeah definitely more
we got about 10 minutes left we see the
options I wonder if you can yeah you can
turn them you can turn the volume down
ok but like
specifically the like sound factors do
that okay cool can't hear more music
a cosmic castaway says heard this game
too simple no he says are this game is
simply fantastic wanna watch every
making of about it was he saying our
because of a pirate maybe yes audio okay
just do them you found the path okay
wait hold on what this is like this is
kind of spoiler yeah I'll cut away yeah
we take a look at us for a little bit
yeah I mean as much as I love the game
like I don't I want to keep like a lot
of things like see where people I'm
happy so like even though the games
don't like visit all the other bosses
but you know it's somethings deserve
[Music]
there's a vintage mode escape came out
today what's your vintage mode is that
something it's what was it there's a
vintage mode on and off I wonder if
that's the filter okay I'm actually
watching out what the spam looks out and
see oh man this looks great though oh we
could have done it there actually oh I
think the songs are a little bit quiet
yeah I agree
nudity I kind of gave that impression it
was right
what sensor I don't know it's like
censored I had a friend's dad growing up
we were like 12 or 13 if there was a new
like a nude scene or I think that like
that in the movie he would go up to the
TV and put his watch and he would just
watch it himself so it's almost like you
and doom all right let me turn these
back up vintage mode
oh it's what's audio it would be maybe
like the
oh it's so it's even more like muted
yeah see it's like coming out of like
seemed like the phone I just leave it
off for now yeah I think it's already
muted enough you know II mean like
alright actually I really like this boss
fight great I hope I hope he goes into
the second phase on simple mm-hmm bull
say where are the cups names on mug man
and Joey's playing on some cherry bombs
with some fire on the ground
cuphead cup it is the red one alright
yeah oh come on jump on using the Rat
King
[Music]
overclock users say it says this game
seems tougher than my ex probably whoa I
pushed me into the bottle caps okay so
this doesn't have the last class phase
that's all right
what why not that's on simple let's try
regular oh I'm missing something
I was the fire oh I thought she thought
that was like wondering like my
secondary looks exactly the same
[Music]
oh hey I think you need some meter
[Music]
Scooter dad yo says these guys need baby
mode Oh
Joey needs a harder mode than expert I
need a baby
[Music]
god damn you so good
[Music]
oh we're close so I want to go with my
super-good - anyway
we got this this timing is tough yeah so
like yeah you have to do you have to
pair you on the ground
Oh oh my god
[Music]
Oh what is that outside is it a bird or
a cat okay oh that's awesome
Oh God nope oh really you're only hot I
can't get through them no mark yeah this
level does have awesome that's the cat
for help so when you do the parry is it
just automatically one card yeah I think
airing is still like
[Music]
nice let's try you behind right and
never lead I
[Music]
how I do oh yeah
[Music]
oh come on because you can
[Music]
Jesus God
[Music]
I'll go around them Oh No Oh No
[Music]
nice dog it's all you pay off co-star to
go back for you close were we
damn I we got our noses to the flag nice
when the finish is together got like
land on it almost
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
Oh super though
[Music]
Oh No
we are very close though like that
that's that whole whole thing is right
there going yeah yeah we had it out yeah
I kinda slipped I did
[Music]
[Music]
I'm never gonna get it
[Music]
what do you use the charge for charge
oh don't use it for yeah like what's
like I've got that and like an enemy
type just one that you're like kind of
moving around a lot so that when you
have to like stop good mouth damage
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
Oh No
[Music]
got this
[Music]
god this game I love this music
[Music]
you worried about it don't worry dude
and when we get there you just if I die
I'm dead do not come back all right
[Music]
[Music]
target
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh my god oh my god we do it that's
probably it right nope
oh no god damn dude alright that's it
we've been close enough to lick the
flagpole build that mirror
I got dashboard
I'm not dashing you have though the
smoke phone right yeah yeah you might be
able to like go through yeah there you
go
[Music]
[Music]
now don't do it do it it
that was weird what you don't I don't
know I like
[Music]
nice alright
well should we call it yeah I don't know
I mean just one more is gonna turn into
like okay well anyway the spiral down to
this mess where you can't get out of
definitely well that'll do it that was
fun I had a good time playing and I hope
you guys did as well thank you guys for
tuning in for a cup head it's out now
it's out today so today there well when
they release when do they like five
years ago something like that yeah a
long time coming again yeah if you guys
are just joining us unfortunately we're
out but you can go back and you know
watch I got the whole stream you can do
that the vaad will be up on YouTube
sometime and on site but um
that's gonna do it for us again it's on
Steam and Xbox one $20 e PC Windows
Windows real stores steam and Xbox one
hip-hop yeah nasty but that's gonna do
it happy Friday everyone thank you for
joining us thank you Joey for carrying
us through as you are a very skilled at
this I need some work thanks to practice
yeah it is what it is tough game fun
game great looking game I'll start on
people thank you guys so much and have a
great rest have a great weekend or yeah
see you see dude
[Music]
you